[Applauso]
[Musica]
che cosa è successo al maestro Ma sta
dormendo ma doveva iniziare la lezione
come fa a dormire Oh forse ci siamo
scappati l'interrogazione
ragazzi controlliamo
maestro tutto bene Ehi perché non si
sveglia Dev essere successo qualcosa AS
Aspettate aspettate ho un brutto
presentimento
vediamo questo è il morso di un
vampiro un vampiro qui a scuola un
vampiro la mattinata si fa interessante
niente verifiche devo subito fare una
foto quando mi R capita di vedere un
morso di un vampiro guardate C'è un
biglietto cosa
dice trovate il
vampiro un vampiro
[Applauso]
[Musica]
io C'è un vampiro a scuola e noi
dobbiamo scoprire Dov'è dobbiamo
risolvere questo mistero proprio come
nel mio nuovo libro La città stregata
che è ora disponibile online in libreria
se non ce l'avete ancora andate a
prenderlo ma ora iniziamo subito la
nostra Challenge per riuscire a trovare
il vampiro più velocemente ci divideremo
in squadre di due io e alici Andremo
nella biblioteca della scuola io
Vittoria e io Lorenzo andremo a cercare
il vampiro fuori in giardino e noi Billy
e zck staremo qua in
classe e cercheremo
graino che cerchiamo abbiamo campo
libero Non c'è il
maestro Mi fai
m biblioteca della scuola Vediamo se
rileviamo la presenza di qualche
creatura qua sì Vediamo se con la nostra
lente riusciamo a capire se il vampiro è
passato da queste parti Esatto io guardo
di qua io
qua qua non trovo niente con questa
lente Dovrei riuscire a rilevare se il
vampiro è passato di
qua Anita vieni qua Forse ho trovato un
indizio lapri questa scia ci sono delle
tracce il vampiro è passato di qua Eh sì
è andato in classe dobbiamo seguirle
presto cercare il bambino noi Voglio
cercare il bambino possiamo divertirci
nessuno può dirci niente Tanto il
maestro sta
dormendo non c'è proprio il maestro Ma
che fatto abamo la classe tuta per noi
vero adesso facciamo
unato prendi
per la prima volta posso fare questo per
la prima volta Oh che
bello ho rotto ho rotto se ne frega
Lini due cucini Aspetta
aspetta che brutto
stupido anche la cacca
ti ho
beccato Uh è uscito un dente un dente e
adesso è il momento del bullo dei balli
del ballo dei bulli ballo dei bulli mi
sono confuso dai tre qua
dai cerchiamo da questa parte magari c'è
qualcosa
io non trovo
niente Senti devo confidarti una cosa Sì
cosa devi dirmi ma sbrigati perché il
vampiro potrebbe essere fuori ho molta
paura tranquilla Ti proteggerò io Oh
grazie Ma sei un po' strano cosa volevi
dirmi devo dirtela all'orecchio
Oh ma cosa mi hai
fatto sono io il
vampiro le tracce portano
qua pago FR un sorgio e ti
sconfiggerò e ti facer con
questo prendi questo e tu prendi
questo Ehi ehi
Ragazze vi sembra il caso di mettervi a
giocare proprio adesso c'è in giro per
la la scuola un vampiro assetato di
sangue e voi pensate a mettere sotto
sopra la classe Siete proprio degli
irresponsabili Sì sì ma che cosa ce ne
frega a noi perché adesso che non c'è
più il
maestro Ah è vero Il maestro non c'è più
dove sarà andato Possiamo fare quello
che vogliamo e quindi ci
divertiamo e poi i vampiri non possono
farsi proprio niente perché io a pranzo
ho mangiato 1 kg di pasta aglio e olio
Senti qua
Ah che
schifo siamo i più fighi
[Applauso]
divertiamoci qua
[Musica]
Questo voi Bulli siete sempre i soliti
Sì lasciamoli qua continuiamo a cercare
Non c'è tempo da perdere Esatto
[Musica]
Andiamo ragazzi attenti sta
arrivando eh Sta arrivando chi sta
arrivando il bambino mia morsa mia morsa
vampiri ma che
vampiri ma non esistono i vampiri Oh
guarda sono un vambino Sono un vampiro
No ti prego mangiarmi
Ah ma che cosa Ma come fai a credere a
certe cose Guarda che St e se i Vampire
non esistono questi Che cosa
sono Guarda c'è Lorenzo laggiù Ah
sì Lorenzo Dov'è Vittoria Ehi Ciao
ragazze come va Eh scusate Ho un po' di
mal di gola come va Vittoria Sì Vittoria
e è scappata aveva paura a rimanere qui
fuori perché ti stai coprendo la bocca
eh scusami Ho un po' di mal di gola
oggi ma com'è possibile che hai lasciato
Vittoria da sola È pericoloso c'è un
vampiro in giro Io ho cercato di
inseguirla ma ho perso le sue tracce non
è possibile L'hai lasciata da sola Ma
dov'è andata Eh penso sia tornata in
classe Io vado in classe e vedo se c'è
vittoria là tu rimani qua con Lorenzo a
cercare il vampiro Ok va bene Anita ma
stai attenta
V sei un po' sospetto Fammi vedere i
denti no i denti cos'è quel sangue nella
tua
mano devo essermi tagliato qui in
giardino cercando il vampiro adesso le
cose quadrano Vittoria che è scappata il
sangue nella mano e ti stai coprendo i
denti Tu sei il vampiro E va bene mi hai
scoperto e ora trasformerò anche
te non credo
proprio no scoperto devo sbrigarmi
Vittoria stai bene Ti stavo cercando Sì
sto benissimo sta benissimo Stiamo tutti
benissimo e fra poco starei benissimo
anche
tu che succede Ma come Ancora non l'hai
capito Guarda
qua ci siamo trasformati in vampiri
manchi solo tu
hai
perso Oh bene ben benelle che cosa
abbiamo qui Brava Vittoria hai
trasformato tutti ne manca solo una eri
tu il vampiro avrei dovuto capirlo
quando ti copri la bocca con le mani
Esatto Non te ne sei accorta e ora
consegnaci subito il libro Daci subito
il
libro Ma io non ho il libro qua come non
hai il libro E allora dov'è il libro Il
libro è
[Musica]
qua bravissima Alice Noi investigatrice
abbiamo vinto abbiamo scoperto chi è il
vampiro e se ancora non ce l'avete
andate subito a prendere la città
stregata in libreria
online Ciao ciao
C